هذا موجز الاخبار من قناه الجزيره اهلا
بكم اعلنا الجيش الاوكراني خوض معارك دامي
اهل منع القوات الروسيه من السيطره على
مدينه باخموت شرقيه البلاد وقال قائد
القوات البريه الاوكرانيه ان الوضع حول
المدينه لا يزال صعبا مؤكدا صدى ضربات
الروسيه والحق خسائر كبيره بالقوه
المهاجمه
في المقابل وصف قائد ميليشيا فاجنرال
الوضع في باخموت بانه صعب للغايه رغم تقدم
مقاتليه مضيفا ان الاوكرانيين يتشبثون بكل
متر فيها
عقد الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن اجتماعا
ثلاثيا مع رئيسي الوزراء الاسترالي
والبريطاني في قاعده بوينتلوم البحريه
بهدف وضع اللمسات الاخيره على اتفاقيه
تزود بموجبها الولايه المتحده استراليا
بغواصات تقليديه تعمل بالطاقه النوويه
وقال بايدن ان هناك التزاما بالعمل
المشترك لضمان بقاء منطقه المحيطين حره
ومزدهره وامنه
بدوره قال الرئيس الوزراء البريطاني ان
الاتفاقيه تهدف الى مواجهه تحديات جديده
تفرضها دول على راسها روسيا
نقلت رويترز عن الجيش الكوري الجنوبي
اعلان هو ان كوريا الشماليه اطلقت صاروخين
فاليستيين قاصيري المدى قباله ساحلها
الشرقيه اليوم كما نقلت عن بيان للجيش
الكوري الجنوبي قوله ان قوته في حاله تاهب
عاليه مؤكدا ان تدريبات المشتركه مع
الولايات المتحده متواصله مثل ما هو مخطط
له
قالت نائبه وزير الدفاع الامريكي ان طلب
الزياده في الانفاق الدفاعي بالموازنه
الجديده للبنتاجون تهدف الى مواجهه
التحديات التي تطرحها الصين وكوريا
الشماليه وفق وصفها
تواصلت خسائر اسهم القطاع المصرفي في
مستهل جلسات التداول الاسيويه بفعل انهيار
بنك سيليكون فالي الامريكي حيث هوى المؤشر
الفرعي للقطاع المصرفي في بورصه طوكيو
لنسبه
6.7% بينما فقدت اسهم البنوك الاستراليه
الكبيره اثنين في المئه من قيمتها
وشهدت مؤشرات سوق الاسهم الامريكيه حاله
من التارجح امس جراء استمرار ازمه بنك
سيليكون فالي وقال الرئيس الامريكيين تحرك
ادارتها السريع لاحتواء الازمه يثبت
للامريكيين ان بامكانهم الثقه في النظام
المصرفي
في تونس اختار نواب البرلمان الجديد
ابراهيم بودربال رئيسا للمجلس باغلبيه
الاصوات وكان البرلمان التونسي قد عقد امس
جلسته الافتتاحيه وسط احتجاجات في صفوف
الصحفيين بعد منعهم من الدخول لتغطيه
الجلسه هذا واستنكرت نقابه الصحفيين منع
منتسبيها من الدخول واكدت انها سابقه
خطيره وقد اعلنت جبهه الخلاص الوطني وحركه
النهضه عدم الاعتراف بهذا البرلمان
من جانب حضر الرئيس التونسي النواب الجدد
من مغبه سحب الشعب الثقه منهم اذا لم
يضعوا التشريعات المناسبه وفق قوله
الى اللقاء